we've been talking to Russian
journalists a lot of them independent
who have moved to YouTube to try to
escape censorship the Kremlin is
tightening its grip on the media and
critics of the Russian president
Independent Media in Russia now silenced
by the Kremlin I don't like German
journalists actually because in Russia
for now it's not a good word actually
and they've been pretty successful in
doing so but now people like Irina who
we just talked to are now on this list
can I share my screen with you really
quick yeah okay so this is right here
yeah those are okay 52 area Okay 52.
this list is a list of foreign agents
people who are either receiving funding
from or influence from foreign entities
they're not branded as foreign agents
within Russia they require to put that
there are foreign agents on their tweets
and on their YouTube videos everyone
knows that they're a foreign agent but
really what foreign agent means is Putin
doesn't like what they say the critical
piece here is that you are subject to
fines and potentially your criminal
investigation for non-compliance so
drama's list and you can also put in a
little disclaimer if they choose to
prosecute they have grounds to do so and
that's the scary part I've been talking
to our story producer who is a Russian
journalist who is helping connect us to
what's going on on the ground
so of the people we've talked to who's
on this list now they're all on it now
everyone they're all on Anna was the
only one
before and now she's on it too too yeah
so everyone we've talked to is a foreign
agent according to the Russian
government Kia and Michael
his list is a new weapon for this regime
to censor voices that it doesn't like
the list is huge and it is growing every
day this is
it's getting bad it's getting really
really bad in this story I want to show
you what life in Putin's Russia is like
today not fed through my Western lens or
through Western media but rather through
the lens of the people who are living
there I reached out to all of you
looking for people in Russia to tell me
what it is like right now to be in this
country what I'm seeing through all of
this is a place that is increasingly
turning back to the old Soviet days in
the process cutting off one of the most
important parts of any society its flow
of information
foreign
[Music]
real quick before we uh dive fully into
today's video I want to thank today's
sponsor who is a long time supporter of
this channel thank you better help for
sponsoring today's video I've said it
once and I will continue to say it I am
a super giant massive believer and fan
of therapy therapy has changed my life I
believe therapy is a thing that in 50
years we will look back and be like
remember back in the 2020s when like
there were people who didn't take their
mental health seriously like I really
believe in therapy and betterhelp is a
platform that is making therapy more
accessible to people normally with
therapy you call around to different
offices and you see if it works with
your insurance and you do all this stuff
and it's complicated and hard and
difficult with better help all you do is
download an app sign up and you answer a
couple of questions and then betterhelp
matches you with someone in their
massive network of tens of thousands of
licensed therapists that are not just in
your city but all around they will find
the best match for you oh and you don't
have to be talking to them if you don't
want to you can do a phone call you can
do a video your chat you can do a text
message if you want for your therapy you
can choose the format that works for you
if you don't like your therapist you can
switch at any time for free which is
another giant perk that if you've ever
done traditional therapy is just like
unheard of I believe therapy is for
everyone I am someone who didn't have a
clinical mental health condition but
like went to therapy and saw the
benefits of how it can change your life
I really really believe that therapy
needs to be more accessible more
normalized and that is why I believe in
what better help is doing if you want to
try out better health there's a link in
my description it is betterhelp.com
Johnny Harris clicking that link helps
support this channel it also gets you 10
off your first month of better help so
you can try it out at a discount see if
it works for you let's dive into this
story about Russia and Russian YouTubers
and information in Russia it is a
fascinating one let's go
[Music]
we got tons and tons of community
submissions for this piece like hours
and hours worth hi Joni hi hello hello
hi hello Johnny hi Johnny hi Johnny
hello Polly hello I'm Russian I'm from
Russia I'm a student from Moscow Russia
so let me get you up to speed on what's
going on here how we got to a Russia
that looks like this and of course it
has to do with this guy it's easy to
think that Vladimir Putin is just this
big bad dictator who's existed forever
ruling Russia but no Butternut Putin was
elected to become the president of
Russia in 2000 back then Russia was a
pretty different place than it is today
he served two four-year terms and by
2008 Putin's time was up the
constitution of Russia expressly
prohibits anyone from being able to be
president for more than two terms like
here in the United States but Putin
wasn't ready to give up on power so he
found a little loophole the Constitution
doesn't say anything about someone
taking a break after their second term
and then coming back and being president
again so Putin this move he got this guy
to become president for four years while
he Putin became the Prime Minister and
this was a good time for the Russian
economy which was opening up to foreign
investment and the economy was growing
nicely this new president of Russia sat
with President Obama and had like a
burger and fries here in Washington DC
in an effort to reset relations between
the two countries but while Putin was
taking this little four-year break he
was not loving all of this as the 2012
election approached he needed to get
back into the top job so he convinced
this President not to run again and
instead to back Putin's presidential bid
in exchange they would just sort of
switch places and this guy would become
the prime minister
and that's exactly how it worked Putin
won the 2012 election and these two just
switched places some people have called
this like gasoline like in chess it's
the only time in the game where you're
allowed to move two pieces at once and
it's a move that's meant to protect the
king so it's 2012 and a bunch of people
in Russia are on to what Putin's up to
they take to the street in protest of
what was clearly one man accumulating
ultimate power in their country all in
an election that outside observers
concluded was not fully free and fair
but none of this mattered because by
2012 Putin is back in power and he's not
going to play nice anymore he cracks
down on these protests and he takes his
control of the country to a new level
making sure that he'll never be
challenged again
started arrested people like me and my
friends regular protesters first by
dozens then by hundreds and then by
thousands across the country
[Music]
the central election of Putin like
became kind of a milestone and this is
like really huge historical events that
um divided our country like our history
uh into you know before and after so
that was like 10 years ago and since
then the people in Russia have kind of
experienced the kind of proverbial frog
and boiling water thing where year after
year they've seen a long but slow
transformation of their society their
rights and perhaps most notably where
they get their information in the past
several years it's it's became a norm to
get beaten up at a protests to get up to
15 days 30 days of detention for taking
part in a protest every single year
people's perception of what the
government can do to them shifted to
accept more and more repressive actions
and this is where that list that I was
looking at kind of started and it
started small and bureaucratic Putin's
party passes this foreign agent law this
saying that any organization in Russia
that receives any money from any other
country is now required to put a big
badge on anything they publish that says
that like hey I'm a foreign agent and if
they don't comply they have to pay a
huge fine at first this just seems like
a bureaucratic thing but this law would
lay a foundation to help the Putin
regime censor whoever they didn't like
all types of media Outlets bloggers TV
channels and even newspapers that don't
support Putin's Ukraine Invasion are
labeled as foreign agents which in
Russian sounds more like foreign spy it
means that anything published by those
outlets now has to include a huge
disclaimer declaring something like this
article was written by a foreign agent
that obeys the west and spreads its
false propaganda the next year they
passed this gay propaganda law claiming
that they must urgently protect Russia's
children against the West's moral Decay
by prohibiting the discussion or
promotion of homosexuality and LGBT
rights among minors you could call this
the original don't say gay law and I
remember this very loud case when the
outload basically
lgbtq plus youth support group and they
took the founders to court it was
incredibly stressful for many many
people because they were doing very good
work they were helping young people who
were confused and scared and maybe not
accepted for their identity and they
were taken to court for us as part of
lgbtq plus Community I can say that we
don't have any rights or freedoms in
Russia it's just not for us and then in
the next year 2014 Putin annexes Crimea
Russian President Vladimir Putin casts
his shadow across the boundary of Europe
and Russia Russian troops spreading out
throughout the Strategic Crimean
peninsula
and this is where we start to see a
giant disconnect between like what
happens in Russia and here in the west
here in the west we saw this land grab
and we were like what is happening this
is so terrible but the fact is most
Russians loved this I mean look at this
guy's popularity it Springs up to an
all-time high after he invades and
steals land and this is because Putin is
really good at appealing to a certain
yearning within a big part of the
Russian population I mean listen to his
annexation speech where he calls Crimea
quote an Inseparable part of Russia is
he claims that he has this firm
conviction that is based on truth and
Justice like Putin is a good Storyteller
he is a strong magnetic leader and we
lose out on that because we don't
understand his language and he just
looks like a villain but many Russians a
lot of them who remember the chaos of
the post-soviet years see Putin as a
strong leader someone who's willing to
stick up for Russian identity and values
in a chaotic and changing world so yeah
super popular but then the West punishes
him by cutting him off from the economy
as punishment for stealing land and
bankrolling a war in the east of Ukraine
and this war in Ukraine drags on instead
of being a quick Victory like he hoped
but if there's anything I've learned
about Vladimir Putin in these years it's
that when he takes a loss he just
responds by doubling down by 2016
Russian Society is starting to look much
less free than it was four years earlier
Putin's government has now passed laws
forcing internet providers to store user
data and to cooperate with Russian law
enforcement even if it means sharing
people's private encrypted messages one
thing that aspiring dictators know is
that staying in power means controlling
what people think and to do that you
must control the information that they
have access to you understood that you
should take under control TV
tonight everything the first Target is
Russian TV channels he chips away at
these until almost all of them are owned
or influenced by the government
eventually there's only one non-state TV
channel standing
but then suspiciously Russia's cable
providers stop airing this TV channel to
18 million Russian homes that
effectively censoring it completely they
get evicted from their studio in
downtown Moscow and by 2015 every
television in Russia is showing a
version of reality that this one man
wants them to see
videos
I mean you're watching this video on the
internet and you're like who cares it's
TV no one watches TV but in Russia
people do watch TV 70 of the population
which is literally like a hundred
million people get their news from TV TV
that they're watching daily like in a
lot of parts of the world the television
is the Gateway that people have to see
the world to understand the world to
make up their minds about the world we
cannot underestimate TV 100 million
people if you like a Russian grandma and
like you're cooking dinner and oh
there's TV on background this is just
like their only source of news like
television and it's terrible uh
propaganda became much more prominent on
TV it was basically the only narrative
you could find there is no TV channels
in Russia that not under the state that
not under the Kremlin nowadays Russian
TV is just one big endless storm of
different kinds of propaganda I just
cannot watch Russian TV it's just
impossible to watch it myself
I mean let's just clarify one thing
every country has totally polarized
slanted television like here in the US
we have news channels that are totally
slanted to one side or the other and
will often just toe the line of
whoever's in power if they align with
their views like this Russian guy
spewing propaganda on Russian State tv
kind of doesn't sound that different to
like Tucker Carlson talking about Donald
Trump the reality is that all
information has a bent has a bias I
really believe that the difference is
that this is all they get you can't
click away to an opposing channel to get
another view I don't speak Russian which
is a big bummer because I really wanted
to just like watch a bunch of Russian TV
and like see what it feels like luckily
Putin's government has me covered check
this out the U.S plan is to drag this
war out as long as they possibly can
this war is a war of the United States
against Europe the Russian government
has built a full-blown international
news outlet that is Russian State TV but
in English and a bunch of other
languages it's called Russia Today
and boy is it a treat there is no home
under heaven for any Ukrainian military
Victory against the Russian professional
Army Ukrainian Fighters caught on camera
using ambulance for transportation this
stuff is super valuable actually because
not only is it like teach us what
propaganda looks like but it also gives
us an alternative view on how these
events are being seen which is really
helpful for questioning your own biases
and trying to make sense of how
information Works in this world RT was
banned from YouTube for being full-blown
propaganda but they still publish their
videos and I found where Bingo RT they
publish a lot of videos like tons and
tons and tons of videos I mean their
news outlet and a lot of it is Putin on
Russia's support for African nations the
anti-hero of the Year oh and look we've
got Tucker Carlson has made an official
they're calling him not only the person
of the year but also the most
influential person in Europe and it's
notable because there have been a number
of people who have been quick to rush to
social media calling out this decision
saying that they don't agree with it and
also referring to the hypocrisy
surrounding it and that includes Fox
News host Tucker Carlson take a listen
to what he had to say about it zielinski
has no interest in freedom and democracy
in fact zelinski is far closer to Lenin
than to George Washington he's a
dictator over the past years yeah so
there's some alignment here I mean a lot
of this stuff is just regular news it's
not all propaganda but it's when you get
into how RT is covering the war in
Ukraine that you kind of start to feel
like you're on drugs people here feel
terrorized by the Ukrainian military who
continue Shilling them every day Ukraine
hates us and that's it they want to
destroy us Ukrainian nationalist forces
continue showing civilians here in the
city of donesk like this documentary
that is just wild it's called nuclear
blackmail and it's a story about a
Ukrainian power plant that a reminder
Russia invaded and is occupying but this
whole documentary is about the poor
locals who are being attacked by brutal
ukrainians totally unprovoked even
though it's Russia who's occupying the
country
okay but wait pause we just have to have
a moment I want to go on with the story
but I also want to just say something
right here because it's actually really
important I've been watching a lot of
Russian TV for this story and while it's
really easy to roll your eyes at this
stuff or laugh at it or condemn it
because some of it is just full on fake
news a lot of this is actually more
subtle not full-blown inventing the
truth and in fact I think the value of
watching this is it shows you the kind
of cherry picking of facts and
interpretations that they're able to do
on their side and then you start to see
the same type of cherry picking that
media companies here in the west do for
the world view that suits them and you
start to realize that all journalism is
at some point cherry picking you're
deciding what to put in and what to
leave out and it often comes with biases
I see the same type of cherry picking
from Western news organizations hell I
do this it's a lot easier for me to
publish a story to you about how bad
Vladimir Putin is than to cover I I
don't know the potential war crimes
committed by Ukrainian soldiers against
Russian soldiers recently based on a
video that The New York Times broke like
I don't want to look into that that
doesn't really line up that's a lot
harder thing to cover it's easier for me
to cover the narrative that fits with
what you all want to see and what you
all believe and that's kind of scary
watching Russian TV it sounds like my
recommend but I'm saying that this
propaganda can help wake us up to what
sensors we need to have on when we're
ingesting information so yeah stay
skeptical and curious and resist the
urge of just Blind Side taking that's my
PSA for today let's get back to the
story
United States is interested in severing
ties between Russia and Europe and also
China okay so back to our timeline it's
2017 100 million Russians are being fed
a version of reality that their
autocratic leader wants them to see but
there's one place that Vladimir Putin
hasn't reached yet and that is the place
that you are currently right now this
place called youtube.com so by 2017 if
you want to be an independent news
Outlet in Russia your life looks like
this at the top of every single tweet
you have to put this which basically
says I am a foreign agent this message
material is created and or distributed
by a foreign mass media performing the
functions of a foreign agent like you
can't even put a tweet here because all
of your characters are taken up by the
foreign agent disclaimer R.I.P anything
good every single one of these and if
you don't do this if you break one
little foreign agent rule you get
slapped with a fine and this is where
the foreign agent loss starts to get
weaponized against journalists one
Outlet did an interview with Putin's big
enemy Alexei navalny soon after they got
hit with a fine for non-compliance with
the foreign agent law they end up having
to pay 340 thousand dollars as a fine
which ends up bankrupting them and they
had to do like a crowdsourcing campaign
to like make the money back they were
almost squashed because of this foreign
agent law this hostile environment for
journalists is what led many to leave
and come to YouTube and one of the major
Pioneers for that was Alexei navalny
yeah
and how badass he is as an opponent to
Putin and how he used YouTube to like
troll Putin while also exposing
corruption in Russia everybody just
watched this and said oh my God so that
what you can do on YouTube that's
Michael he's a Russian YouTuber who you
will hear more from in a second Alexa
navalny showed that you could have huge
audiences on YouTube saying things that
weren't really allowed to be said
anywhere else and media companies could
actually make money without advertisers
fleeing because they are foreign agents
in Russia that you don't have a lot of
choice if you want to be in mid-ass Fair
kakras is
another huge Pioneer in all of this was
this guy Yuri dude he started in 2017
and was an instant hit so it is
this guy was a sports journalist he
didn't set out to like completely
reshape journalism in Russia but he did
yes
sex like I watch this stuff and I don't
fully know how to make sense of it it
doesn't fit into any box that I'm used
to these videos are super long we're
talking like hour and 56 minutes 12
million views hour and 54 minutes 22
million views Yuri dudes videos are like
I don't know 60 Minutes blended with
Anderson Cooper but mixed with a little
Jimmy Kimmel's celebrities read mean
tweets all of this except for like
Anderson Cooper is reading the tweets
and he probably wrote some of them too
also Anderson Cooper is wearing a hoodie
oh and all of this is taking place on
YouTube a website where millions of
Russians are watching two and a half
hour long interviews with guests they
maybe never heard of I mean this is wild
like I'm a YouTuber I'm a storyteller I
don't understand this but what I do
understand is 10 million subscribers and
like 22 million views this guy paved the
way for a new set of Russian voices in
an independent space outside of the
grasp of the Putin regime people who
watch TV they believed some things for
eight years while people who watched
YouTube they had totally different
opinion you could find interviews with
like politicians opposition politicians
in Russia that you wouldn't otherwise
see on TV
[Music]
um
another Pioneer in this space is Irina
sheikman who I got to talk to for the
story Irina came from TV as well she was
like a traditional host who took the
leap to go to YouTube and found Freedom
she's a foreign agent she has to put the
foreign agent disclaimer at the front of
every one of her videos I'm a foreign an
agent don't give me advertising money
squash me and make me feel little
because Vladimir Putin hates me her
videos are incredibly professional and
very well done very interesting
conversations
well
um
we also got to talk to Karen shenyan an
openly gay journalist in a country that
criminalizes quote gay propaganda
chanyan launched a YouTube channel about
queer culture and identity in 2020.
because there is no any other place to
put any freedom of speech interest
you just can't and everything is like
closed blocked and canceled this is the
only platform that is still a safe
Russian authorities cannot technically
they cannot block your YouTube channel I
launched my own YouTube channel starting
with a series of interviews with uh open
the queer people and I actually started
it with like American guests because
none of Russian celebrities would even
imagine that they can participate in
such a project YouTube was a safe place
for a long time it was the place where
these journalists could publish to huge
audiences to say what they want to be
able to run a business to get
advertisement and like I said at the
beginning everyone we talk to every
journalist is now a foreign agent they
are now on a registry with their name
their birthday their tax number and
their classification as a foreign agent
and this
this is what's developing right now the
Putin regime has not been Savvy enough
to really crack down on the internet the
same way that maybe China has done but
what they are doing is using this
familiar soviet-style registry to create
enemies of the people the people they
don't like they put on a list they make
them taboo they make what they have to
say not valid anymore and in doing so
they start to extend their control to
these spaces that used to be free but
while YouTube has remained outside of
the grasp of Vladimir Putin in his
regime it doesn't mean that it's totally
safe everything changed on February 24th
When The War started
foreign
you need to choose a side so if you
don't speak about that you choose the
side of Russian government you should
decide of Russian army and Vladimir
Putin who killed people right now so
it's a still a position even if you just
mute
foreign
within a week of the invasion the
parliament pushed through a series of
draconian censorship laws things like
publishing false information about the
Russian government or the Russian
military could now land you in prison
for 15 years what this meant is that
Russians couldn't call this a war
they had to play by the silly pretend
term special military operation and this
wasn't just on paper so far over 4 000
journalists have been prosecuted under
these new censorship laws
God I'm not even sure we still have any
rights my rights and freedoms I feel
they are constantly disappearing from
Russia after the invasion all
Independent Media has either ceased to
exist or was physically forced out of
country someone can actually get
arrested and serve time if they just say
the word war no you didn't mishear me
just simply were not even war or War
sucks because now we have to call it a
special operation speaking out on social
media became dangerous journalists fled
the country soon after the law was
initiated the censorship became really
strong like way stronger than even
before me personally I condemned this
war publicly and lost about 100
000 subscribers just from my opinion I
am really
shocked by people who are protest now in
a good way they are amazing people
they're really brave persons that that's
an act of Bravery nowadays to go in the
protests companies
but the Kremlin has stopped short of
actually shutting down YouTube in part
because they have an incentive to keep
it open a lot of Russian propagandists
use the platform to spread their message
everyone since the beginning of War has
been saying well they go into block
YouTube tomorrow in a week in two weeks
but there were constant rumors that
YouTube was going to be blocked in guess
what it is not my theory is that they
don't have capacitors capacities in
order to block YouTube they just are not
capable of doing that YouTube is kind of
game changer in the modern Russian media
landscape for YouTube YouTube became
like the worst Boston of freedom of
speech free from common censorship here
in Russia our government wants to close
YouTube but they can't because they
they're afraid of big outrage it's hard
to underestimate the value of YouTube
nowadays Russian speaking YouTube
creators are now in the tough situation
because all the videos shot for the
Russian audience are now fully
demonetized but we still continue to
make videos because who else is gonna
tell the truth if not us a lot of us
will continue to do what we do because
we do it not for actually views or
subscribers like the count of them but
because we think that it's very
important it was clear to me that it if
you are an independent journalist and
you're not safe anymore to stay in the
country so I
flee to First Armenia and later I ended
up here in Berlin and yet even from afar
they're able to broadcast to Their
audience and share the truth to be an
independent voice in a place that is
more and more cut off from information
if it wasn't for Putin and his system
like there are so many people in Russia
who can like do really great things
Putin and his peers they're just not not
letting us do that and it's terrible and
tragic
so Vladimir Putin has been in power for
23 years and his goal is finally Within
Reach his regime today has a near
Monopoly on information and while
YouTube has been a Haven for independent
journalists and dissenting voices to be
able to share their perspectives but
he's moving in on that too threatening
to punish them if they don't put this
big sign on all of their content that
says they are influenced by Foreign
agents or what this sign really says
which is that these these people these
journalists these voices have been
deemed an enemy of the people I feel the
deepest grief and the deepest you know
guilt and the special responsibility for
every murder that happened in Ukraine
because of the Russian the first war I
never really thought of myself as a
patriotic person and now when I see that
my country is destroying another country
and it's basically destroying itself
that's painful to watch in Russia of
course there's a long way to go but I do
feel like Russia is going like tiny
little steps especially because the
young people are having all this access
to information like mines are being
opened thank you to YouTube we have a
chance we have opportunity even in
dictatorship to spread information uh
to people to people in Russia not in
Russia every part of world even when
dictators tried to kill
every possibility of freedom of speech
actually I'm very optimistic and soon we
gonna see a totally different country or
maybe
several countries
on the territory of Russia
YouTube
journalists
peace to Ukraine freedom for us
hey thanks for watching and thank you to
the many many many Russian people who
spoke to me a lot of them on the
condition of anonymity because for
obvious reasons I don't even need to say
why and to the YouTubers who spoke to me
there's so much more uh in these
conversations that I couldn't include um
I'm going to publish some of this over
on The Newsroom The Newsroom is our
patreon where you can come and support
independent journalism here on YouTube
on The Newsroom we published an extra
video every month the video is a behind
the scenes on how we do what we do and
you can see it all you can see the
behind the scenes of this wild and crazy
studio and all of the people who are
here helping make these videos possible
we also publish uncut interviews and you
get royalty-free music from our composer
Tom Fox and you get to see my scripts if
you want to see how my scripts are made
which are not just scripts they're very
involved documents that I use to direct
these videos but most importantly it's a
way to support what we're trying to do
here which is rigorous independent
journalism on on YouTube which I don't
know if YouTube was ever meant to to
support this but we're finding out so
other ways you can support are
purchasing our Luts and presets which
are the way that we color our videos and
photos we develop those with the
professional colors they're really good
and you can just be here watching the
vids commenting sharing doing all the
things
um I appreciate everyone here and the
the attitude they have of trying to make
us all smarter and better and more
Curious
um
just a lot of that positive energy in
this community and I really appreciate
it so thank you all but and I guess what
I'm feeling a lot of right now is just
gratitude that I can say whatever I want
to say here and um I don't have a big
powerful scary government
um telling me that I'm a foreign agent
or that I'm not allowed to say that I
take that for granted and I don't think
I should because it's really special
that we get to do this so anyway
um hope you all are having a good winter
and I'll talk to you soon